adjacent to known reality lies an
infinite abyss of liminal spaces and
monstrous beings the back rooms as with
all unusual and supernatural phenomena
the SCP Foundation was set on cataloging
the back rooms as an anomaly and finding
a way to contain it but unfortunately
all it took was one failed experiment
for the opposite to occur a huge portion
of sight 19 has begun no clipping into
the yellow walled Maze of the back
room's first level taking the research
team some d-class and a handful of
mobile task force agents into the
disturbing alternate reality with it but
this isn't the most terrifying part just
before the experiment went wrong
scp-096 aka the shy guy was transported
to the testing area of site 19 to be
used as a means of clearing back rooms
entities from the path of the research
team in the midst of the chaos that
ensue food while Dimensions fused 096
was exposed to the Gaze of a shadowy
being known as a Smiler and was able to
instantly Break Free of containment
sprinting through the maze towards The
Smiler
scp-096 was quickly too far away for the
foundation staff to attempt recapture
moreover this situation demanded a far
more immediate concern there was no
apparent way to no clip the Lost
portions of the site back to Native
reality the researchers d-class and MTF
Personnel who were now on the other side
would have to adapt and fend for
themselves in this new reality agent
Cullen the highest ranking member of the
mobile task force present identified
several hostile entities approaching
these bundles of arms were known as
clumps and since they did not possess
eyes they had evaded 096's wrathful
response to entities that saw its face
on Cullen's orders the the researchers
and d-class took cover behind the agents
who opened fire on the clumps meanwhile
scp-096 caught up to The Smiler that had
glimpsed its face in most cases smilers
are highly dangerous entities that prey
on humans who are trapped in the back
rooms by pulling them into the Shadows
because this was its nature The Smiler
was not prepared for 096 to not only
Approach at top speed but to deliver a
slamming arm thrust straight into the
creature's face The Smiler instantly
knew that one more blow like that would
be the destruction of its strange
monstrous existence but it was too late
to get away and 096 certainly didn't
stop at one after beating the Smiler to
a pulp
scp-096 briefly returned to a more
neutral state of being it was not at all
phased by the new surroundings in fact
it was temporarily relieved by the
Solitude of the back room's maze that
was when scp-096 felt the gay something
unknowbly powerful staring at it from
deeper within the back room's Dimensions
scp-096 was no stranger to being
remotely viewed and becoming enraged by
it but this was different these eyes
were everywhere and nowhere all at once
scp-096 felt like it was being torn
apart by its own violent impulse to
destroy whatever entity was currently
seeing its face with no clear Target
present
scp-096 dropped to all fours and in an
instant it ran like a mad Beast through
every conceivable Corridor of the
infinite yellow maze in less than a
single second during this blindingly
fast Rampage 096 found itself back near
the foundation Personnel for a fraction
of a moment none of the humans present
could perceive the shy guy at the
Hypersonic speed it was going but the
result of it passing by was evident in
the abrupt death of several MTF agents
who were still focused on fending off
the
it was collateral damage to 096 who
didn't intend for its speeding body to
collide with the agents but in any case
the clumps were at that much more of an
advantage when it came to brutally
attacking the members of the research
team the clumps's numbers were
increasing as well as more of the fleshy
aberrations rolled forth from the
woodwork one of the d-class
d-3461 panicked breaking away from the
defensive line and bludgeoning an MTF
agent from behind the others were still
reeling from the sudden Slaughter
created by scp-096 and were not quick
enough to stop d-3461 from turning tail
and running off into the maze with a
stolen mobile task force issue firearm
clumps seemed to ignore this and focused
on the larger group of humans present
closing in well a clump of clumps senior
researcher Dr Hart an expert in reading
the body language of anomalous creatures
notice this idiosyncratic movement
immediately she immediately notified the
rest of the research team that the
clumps seem to prioritize going after
humans in groups as much as it was a
cliche in horror and Adventure media it
seemed like the best course of action
was to split into groups of two or three
and run in all directions without
momentum the clumps weren't especially
fast and given the sharp turns and
numerous crisscrossing Pathways to the
back room's first level the humans could
with a head start keep themselves at a
safe distance if they use their brains
and less cumbersome limbs to maximum
efficiency Dr Hart chose her most
trusted scientific understudy Dr
Whitaker as her Retreat buddy and the
two began to hurry down the many
hallways away from the clumps if there
was a way to survive these entities even
on their home terrain it would be
through the superior intellect of the
researchers that is what Dr Hart
believed in her doctor's heart she and
the others who followed her plan were
lucky that 096 had stopped zooming
through the Maze of the back rooms is
first level this was because it realized
that the entity or entities which were
looking at it were not here in this
Dimension or rather this level of the
back rooms but that didn't mean that
whatever it was could hide for long
especially not from
scp-096 the shy guy was capable of many
things when provoked by another being
seeing its face and among the most
obvious was its nigh invulnerability and
extreme speed both of these factors
would come into play as scp-096
attempted a bizarre and fascinating feat
the Shy Guy's entire body shivered
vibrating in place at an even faster
velocity than it had used to cross the
infinite maze in an instant moments
prior this unorthodox psychic straining
movement pattern made scp-096 especially
prone to no clipping which was the only
reliable way to navigate between levels
of the back rooms the sustained
vibration was highly damaging to 096's
body but it felt no pain and the broken
bones and frayed muscles were returned
to normal instantaneously furiously and
with no further preparation
scp-096 no clipped through the floor of
the Maze and began to descend through
the known levels of the back rooms
towards the offending entity that was
still looking at its face down one level
then two then three the pressure of
maintaining this feat would more than
likely kill or incapacitate any other
being including many of scp-096's fellow
powerful anomalies but that level of
endurance was what made as cp096 so
distinct and so Unstoppable four levels
down five levels down as scp-096
continued to descend the scattered
Personnel from the foundation were
making their own discoveries about no
clipping through the back rooms
d-3461 had found himself in a strange
new level of the back rooms filled with
sewer pipes and swooping death moths the
rifle he had taken with him would prove
to be ample protection for now but he
knew his ammunition wouldn't be there
forever still taking his chances
sneaking around down here felt better
than trying to go back towards anyone
who knew him from the foundation like
most d-class d-3461 formerly known as
Gene Beatty was a hardened criminal
through and through and he had done
unforgivable things prior to his time
contained by the SCP Foundation he
didn't want to go back not to the
foundation not to prison and not even to
the real world forget them all he
thought he would survive in this hellish
Abyss known as the back rooms with only
his malice and sense of
self-preservation to guide him agent
Cullen on the other hand who was
accompanied by two of his surviving
mobile task force subordinates was
focused on patrolling the yellow Maze
and searching for potential human
survivors if other people had been no
clipping into the back rooms for as long
as the foundation's data suggested it
was possible that enough of those
unfortunates were able to carve out a
life for themselves that a sizable
faction had formed over the years such a
group would always have a need for armed
assistance and well-trained soldiers so
Cullen knew he could easily find himself
a place among them from there he would
do everything in his power to muster
resources track down the scattered
Foundation personnel and ultimately
return home they have to be around her
somewhere he told himself and his agents
of all the now hopelessly lost
researchers it seemed that Dr Hart and
Dr Whitaker had made it the farthest
into the back rooms they were both now
wandering in the infinite Hotel
otherwise known as level 5 a sprawling
Labyrinth of Suites and lobbies that
would rival the finest establishments in
the front rooms of reality that is if it
were not not also full of the same kind
of hostile entities that were so common
through the back rooms Dr Whitaker
attempted to stay in High Spirits
however making a sophomoric joke about
needing a vacation from his vacation Dr
Hart groaned but on some level she was
grateful to have her younger and more
eccentric colleague close by though he
lacked Common Sense he was a prodigy at
science and more than that he was loyal
the two of them would need teamwork and
perseverance to keep going in this place
and through her mentorship of the young
man the groundwork was already there he
and I will manage somehow Dr Hart
affirmed in her mind elsewhere several
levels down
scp-096 had arrived at the source of the
strange gaze that had been fixed upon it
in level 11 of the back rooms the city
which fittingly enough resembled a
modern human city of vast proportions
scp-096 was found locked onto the entity
known as Argos entity 71 4. an ancient
eyeless humanoid whose Vision was
pervasive and near omniscient throughout
the back rooms the cruel and judgmental
being could observe the sins of any
sentient creature that entered the back
rooms and would carry out a brutal
punishment accordingly this was its
routine behavior and it didn't single
out scp-096 anymore than it did
d-3461 whose sins were much more severe
in the eyes of Argos due to the ill
intent behind them that is not to say
that Argos saw the shy guy as innocent
even out of perceived defense the amount
of lives that scp-096 had taken was on
principle enough to call even the most
well-meaning being a sinner a fight
between Argos and the shy guy was
inevitable Argos was accompanied by
several scores of spear wielding
Warriors in tactical gear human
explorers who had joined his cause they
would prove to be little more than speed
bumps as scp-096 made skid marks out of
them on its way to Pummel the
ever-loving snot out of Argos but Argos
was not going to allow the sacrifices of
his eyes to be in vain The Entity used
the reach of his spear to strike 096 at
a distance impaling the creature in
mid-run to the ground this held the shy
guy for all but a moment before it moved
its body up the spear and slammed into
Argos throwing the two of them through a
nearby building Argos fought desperately
to remove his spear from his opponent's
body as all the while 096 pounded him
with punches that could each reduce an
automobile to scrap metal the two
interlocked monsters tumbled through
wall after wall of the skyscraper taking
the lives of several unlucky human
citizens in the process when Argos pride
is spear free from 096 he immediately
jumped back several Paces but once again
he had underestimated the shy guy who
was at his throat in seconds passersby
on the street watched in horror as 0-9
hurled Argos by the throat into the
skyscraper directly across from the one
they had been fighting in Argos crashed
through the glass of one of the windows
and into an office floor one Titanic
leap from the shy guy later and 096 had
joined Argos on this new fighting stage
Argos to roll this spear in a frenzied
display of combat prowess if this thing
insisted on advancing towards him with
no regard for its well-being it would
have to go through his spear multiple
times over but 096 was not the kind to
let fear stop it from advancing it
charged taking every attack Argos could
dish out before pummeling him downward
through several floors of the building
until they reached the ground level
scp-096 could have taken far more
punishment but Argos had reached his
limit The Entity spear fell from his
hand as 096 continued to hit harder and
harder over and over again until Argos
was close to death as an immortal
backrooms entity could be
at the very least he had been injured so
severely that his All-Seeing gays had
become weakened for the shy guy this
meant that Argos was technically no
longer looking at it it became docile
once more and wandered out of the
building into the streets to its relief
and to the relief of the nearby entities
the facelings of this city had no eyes
and no interest in looking at 096
preferring to continue their mindless
pantomime of normative life aren't we
all in a cosmic sense regardless
scp-096 walked through the streets of
the city with one goal return home but
home was far far away from where the shy
guy was and the no clipping maneuver
that it performed earlier was not
something that the anomaly could muster
the recklessness to do at all times only
when its face was glimpsed did scp-096
possess its murderous determination at
the moment
scp-096 was like a morning jogger
traveling through level 11 at a Brisk
pace and searching for a way out this
naturally led the anomaly towards the
Suburban neighborhoods which were
themselves an entrance to the back rooms
level 9. Suburbia it was here on the
dark streets of the Limitless suburbs
that 096 encountered A New Nightmare the
neighborhood watch comprised of a series
of hostile entities resembling in part
human eyeballs these ocular adversaries
were known to patrol Suburbia and keep
the peace by eliminating all Intruders
of course the floating Watchers were
capable of shooting disintegration beams
while the Towering Striders possessed
sinewy limbs that could easily bash most
entities into submission but
unfortunately for everyone involved they
were giant eyeballs one look from the
neighborhood watch in the direction of
scp-096 and their Fates were sealed
being ogled by humongous eyeballs was
simply more than the shy guy take with a
primal Screech it ran towards the
oversized peepers with a massacre on its
mind a few of the Watchers had time to
fire disintegration blasts which slowed
the approach of scp-096 but it was too
little too late
scp-096 smashed into the Strider
knocking it to the ground and delivering
a crushing blow to its pupil without
missing a beat
scp-096 leaped into the air and smashed
one of the Watchers against a Charming
Suburban home the shy guy Rampage would
continue until there were no more eyes
on it in the back rooms or anywhere now
check out scp-096 versus scp-343 and
scp-096's sad end for more